[Music]
if you've ever had a question whether
the mainstream media distorts whips up
throws things out of focus or has an
agenda especially when it comes to the
Trump administration look no further
than coronavirus if you listen to the
mainstream media it's time to buy the
family burial plot visit the cemetery
where the dirt is definitely cleaner
than your kitchen counter or your
bathroom handles the corona virus
outbreak has the potential to become a
global pandemic the president is a
reality strike the response to the
corona virus in the United States is
being led by the most incompetent and
ignorant president in history so what's
the downside of their doomsday reporting
the downside is predictable when people
are scared when people think it's just a
question of time before they start
dropping like flies they go into
survival mode they don't spend money the
economy suffers they don't invest the
market suffers they talk about taking
their children out of school education
suffers they talk about cancelling mark
March Madness Coachella and local
businesses suffer and canceling Airlines
and cruise ship reservations the economy
suffers they go into depression mode
because their quality of life is over
and who better to trumpet a slowing
economy than CNN Wall Street is rattled
by the worldwide outbreak of the corona
virus the Dow closing down more than 350
points a day for a total loss of more
than 3,000 points over the past week my
my you want to focus on the Dow now
where were you when the Dow the sp500 a
Nasdaq all repeatedly reached record
highs under President Trump you weren't
interested then were you where were you
when the Dow closed at a record high
more than 100 times since Donald Trump's
election where were you when animal
spirits were driving this country to new
economic
and for your information our economy can
sustain a 3,000 point drop because we
are at record highs job numbers just
came out and they're up beyond
expectations the stock market is up for
the week long-term interest rates are
plunging so people can refinance and
those who need subsidies are going to
get them and the media complains that
there was a lackluster initial response
by the Trump administration say what
let's start with the fact that the US
has one of the best health care systems
in the world and on January 31st the
Trump administration restricted entry
into this country from China in an
effort to count to the spreading
coronavirus outbreak even the New York
Times noted the administration barred
entry by most foreign nationals who had
recently visited China American
travelers were under quarantine as the
administration declared a rare public
health emergency the president did this
knowing that it would send shocks
through the stock market that it would
rattle industry between the world's two
largest economies he immediately put
together the smartest most sophisticated
team of doctors scientists and health
care professionals to deal with his
declared coronavirus health emergency
and most important he is signed to vice
president Mike Pence the job of
organizing monitoring a team to contain
mitigate and treat the problem working
with states and local governments his
efforts have been nonstop keenly focused
and heralded the political criticisms by
the left like governor Inslee of
Washington State and Governor Cuomo of
New York State are nothing more than
political gamesmanship that have no
place in this effort the effort to
develop a vaccine making testing kits
available to every state lab and
available to every doctor in this
country with a minimum of four million
dollars going to each of the 50 states
is underway so what to do
it's a virus like the flu it actually
can be mistaken for the flu a sore
throat a cough a fever and by the way it
is flu season you say but people are
dying sadly that's true and not only our
condolences in order but we owe it to
their families and all Americans to come
up with a vaccine like the flu tests for
corona virus are now being made
available to every state lab clinical
trials will begin within five weeks for
the vaccine the federal government is
working continuously vigorously and
forcefully to cut the bureaucratic red
tape that often slows down vaccine
approval and rest assured the best the
brightest and the resolute are working
nonstop to create this vaccine now they
say the mortality rate for corona virus
is higher than a flu but consider though
that we have a flu vaccine and yet in
2019 16,000 Americans died from the flu
imagine if we did not have the flu
vaccine the flu would be a pandemic so
all the talk about corona virus being so
much more deadly doesn't reflect reality
without a vaccine the flu would be far
more deadly now what we do know is the
mortality rate is much higher among
elderly adults according to reports the
risk of dying if infected with the
corona virus is higher the older you are
which might explain why they say
children are not really affected by the
virus but in addition to age as dr.
Anthony pouchy has said the risk is
greater if you as an elderly person have
an underlying medical condition like
diabetes heart disease asthma
it is certainly higher if you're a
smoker which might explain why China has
such a high mortality rate some studies
have estimated that as many as 50% of
Chinese men are smokers
sick of the virus but not from the virus
people die that's what happens in life
the BP oil spill was going to end the
world and every other we've ever had and
so what to do
wash your hands I know everyone think
that thinks there's got to be more to
this the reason you wash your hands is
to get the germs off the reason why you
need to get the germs off is because you
can then transfer them to your eyes your
nose your mouth risking infection to
your respiratory system you're looking
now at a California genius a medical
doctor from their State Health
Department lecturing how not to touch
your face as the woman repeatedly
touches the surface then her face and
literally but their fingers in her mouth
whatever you have to do don't touch your
face and gloves won't matter because the
virus can last for hours on them and
surfaces so whether you need to borrow
your dog shock collar or go out and buy
a straitjacket don't touch your face
don't share drinking glasses eating
utensils clean all hai touch surfaces
every day like counters and tabletops
and doorknobs and stay home if you feel
sick
and as the Surgeon General said on
justice last week you don't need a mask
unless you're sick and there's no need
to go out and clean out the store
shelves as the weather warms fewer and
fewer people will get sick with the
virus some of the meds need to be left
for people who may need them and if you
want to complain about something
complain about the fact that we rely on
China and even India for ingredients for
some of our medication even the meds
themselves like nuclear medicine and
mali 99 it's time to have a supply chain
for our medicine in the United States
time to make America first there so
maybe Bill Maher has the right attitude
stop panicking fear-mongering hiding
under your bed and
freaking out in fact snap out of it
and wash your damn hands wash him and
then wash him again and that's my open
let me know what you think on my
Facebook and Twitter hashtag judge
Janine